welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast
my name is hisham azuz and today
i'm going to talk to you about why i've
changed the name
where his recruitment mentors came from
and uh
what we're trying to build at
recruitment mentors
so why have i decided to change the name
as all of you should know if you've been
listening to this podcast
it was formerly known as the recruitment
rollercoaster podcast and
that podcast i started from my bedroom
when i worked in recruitment and uh it's
been on a
interesting journey to say the least
from
uh joining huxo media and then helping
me take it to the next level and
doing it in a studio compared to my
bedroom
to uh going
recording in all parts of the the
country from
uh leeds to birmingham to manchester
even had uh it booked to do a
live podcast show in australia which had
to cancel because of covid
uh to the the first live event which
some of you may have been which was uh
amazing and uh had the second
live event booked in for march with 200
people that
that paid to to be there that again
had to postpone and cancel
but we've changed the name i changed the
name
because i got to the sort of 200 episode
mark
and it just felt right to take a bit of
a step back
and think about how can i take this
podcast
to the next level for all of you
listening how can i improve
the podcast how can i ensure that
i get more out of the recruiters and
recruitment entrepreneurs
i get on the podcast so really
why i've changed the name is because
i wanted to rebrand it in line with
a bit of a a new chapter
and a slightly new approach
and also of course to rebrand it in line
with the business i'm launching
called recruitment mentors which is a
dedicated learning and development
community
exclusive to recruitment consultants so
it just made sense and
i wanted to also take the opportunity to
try and level it up
so for the last few episodes that i've
been recording that will be released
very soon the mission and the intention
behind the episode is still very much
there which is
to deconstruct how
some of the best recruiters and
recruitment entrepreneurs
have accelerated their recruitment
career how they've achieved what they
have
how they have remained at the top of
their game by
uncovering their habits their mindset
their approach to leadership
their day plans you name it
just so much that we dig into so
the slight change of format just means
that i'm really just
trying to do my best to dig into what
all of you want to find out which is
what do they do differently what do they
do day to day
what do they see coming what changes
have they made
and the goal here is for all of you that
listen to this podcast to take away
the parts that you like take away the
things that you learn
so you can apply that to your own
recruitment career and hopefully that
will give you the best possible chance
of maximizing
your potential so the new chapter of
this podcast recruitment mentors
hopefully
you will all agree and feel that it's a
positive one it's a it's a
hopefully you'll really sense that i've
tried to
level up the podcast so
why have i launched recruitment mentors
the the dedicated learning and
development community
exclusive to recruitment consultants
well if i'm honest
this idea wouldn't have happened or
wouldn't wouldn't have been cultivated
if it wasn't for this podcast and
all of you that listen to this show and
if i'm honest it's
it's come from two places one this
podcast
because i get tons of messages every
single week of recruiters going
really enjoyed that episode learned so
much from that recruiter
hisham do you know someone that can help
me with this he shouldn't you know
someone that could be a good mentor
hisham could you um introduce me to
someone that can help me
um with this certain part of recruitment
and
i just thought why should the learning
stop after the 45 minute hour
episode like why should it stop there
so that was the first reason and the
sort of first part of this
and then the other part is if i'm honest
this is the sort of why behind this
business that
just really resonates with me because i
can relate to it and if i'm honest was
the driving force
to why i started this podcast when i
worked in the recruitment industry
and that's the this just real
belief that every single recruitment
consultant every successful recruitment
consultant
has had help getting there and
for me i think that if you're a
recruiter that
has the inner drive and ambition to want
to learn and develop and be the best
recruiter you can be
which if you listen to this podcast
you're in that category
then you should have an unrestricted
opportunity
to better yourself and that's something
that
i felt like i didn't have in my
recruitment career and if i'm honest
that's what spurned on
this idea of starting a podcast where i
could learn from other recruiters
outside
of my four walls of the office that i
worked in
now the challenges and problems that you
might face
even though that you have that inner
drive and that ambition
is that sometimes a recruitment
consultant's growth can be stunted or
limited
depending on where you can access
learning and development
in your recruitment career so it might
be the the recruiting agency you work
for
they don't earn enough money to put
money aside or in
a pot for learning development or it
might be that the manager and leader
that you learn most from
you're limited by their time and they're
busy
or it might be that you do have an
in-house l d
team but actually you want to know how
to learn
to sell more retain business or you want
to learn how to build communities
and your lnd um function don't have
that expertise internally so it might
just be that
whatever agency that you've ended up
working for
their appetite to invest in learning
development
may just be non-existent and all of
those potential challenges and
limitations
on your potential growth and development
as a recruiter
all of those there that i've just listed
and there might be more
they sit outside of your control
and that's hopefully where recruitment
mentors can create a place for you to go
if you feel like you're experiencing
those frustrations or challenges
or limitations because i really believe
that if you've got that inner desire to
learn and develop then why should you be
restricted
by things outside of your control so
that's where this business has come from
the why behind the business
and hopefully the problem that um we're
going to solve
and the reason why i keep saying we is
not because i want it to sound bigger
than it is it's because
there's a handful of people that i've
got involved to support
me to do this and are involved in the
business and i've actually met
through this podcast and built
relationships with them they've been on
this podcast
um the i felt are really aligned uh with
this mission and the why and also can
have a real impact
on giving us the best chance of making
uh this community and business
successful
so how can you get involved
well the first way because what we're
doing
is a bit of a staggered approach to this
before everyone can access it
so initially what we're doing is a
founder launch
and there's only going to be 20 founding
members of this community and the idea
here and why we're starting here is
because we wanted
20 people 20 recruitment consultants
that
after um completing a short discovery
form
and speaking to me which is the next
part of the process and working out
together if
so we think that they're aligned with
our member values
and also just have an understanding as
to why they want to be involved
um that these 20 people could be amazing
ambassadors for this community so not
only will they get sort of first
access to this community but actually
they'll they'll have a real say on what
this community will look like and
they'll actively share their opinion
give feedback and
really be involved in the building of
this community
to really make sure that it's um
with all of you in mind it's members
first and we're
creating and curating uh this community
with content that you
that recruiters want so
the first way that you can get involved
with this and you're able to do this
um by the end of the week which is
the uh 23rd of
uh february which is the the last day
that you can um apply
and actually complete the short
discovery form in joining the founding
20.
so if you want to if you want to have
the opportunity to be part of this
community
from the very beginning and help shape
this community
then make sure that you check out the
founding20.recruitmentmentors.com page
um where it's all explained in terms of
what the steps are and i'll put
a link in the um show notes if you want
to check that out
then the next part of the launch is
we're going to do a sort of soft launch
in december so
the the founding 20 will have access to
it for a couple of weeks
they'll be involved in giving us
feedback um saying look we'd
i think that you could put more of this
in there or it's missing this
hopefully we can make some changes and
then we'll have an initial launch
where um recruiters will be able to join
this community
um within a two-week period in december
where then we'll then close the doors of
the community after
so there'll be a two-week window in
december where you'll be able to join
this community
and the reason why we're doing it like
that that is because
if i'm honest we want to make sure that
the
quality of this community not only from
the members that are joining it but also
obviously most importantly the content
and the people that you're going to
learn from
and the community um is as good as it
can be
before we just leave it open uh
forever so there'll be an opportunity if
you if you're not
picked as a founding 20 bit you applied
to then have early access to this
community
um where it would then be closed um up
until probably around the sort of
february march time
where they're more drive towards an
official launch um
and hopefully during that period um it
will be a really nice journey where
people can have access to the content
learn from the amazing people that will
be initially in there and also
um have a reactive say on what what we
need to add to this community what would
they love to learn more about
who would you recommend for us to get
involved and be a content contributor
and mentor to the platform
so just really take it as an opportunity
to take as much feedback as possible
so when we get to the official launch
that um
we're really confident in this community
and what it can offer
so that's the sort of timeline and how
you can get involved
if you're listening to this and if you
have any questions feel free to drop me
a message but in terms of this podcast
it's going to remain the same i'm going
to continue bringing
the best recruitment billers i can find
and speak to from across the world in
different markets different locations
and recruitment entrepreneurs so you can
learn from
what's worked for them what didn't work
for them
learn from their mistakes take the parts
that you do
like and hopefully as i said that you
can then take that information and apply
it
to your own recruitment career
so i hope you really
do enjoy the the episodes to come
and you notice this sort of hopefully
the the effort that i'm trying to
level up uh this podcast with i'm gonna
hopefully try and make you feel a lot
more
involved in shouting about the reviews
that people live shout and
leave that shout about the messages that
i get i want to make sure that you're
part of this journey
so if you want to be involved in this
podcast
be involved with recruitment mentors
best place to get me is on linkedin make
sure you're connected with me
and if you don't want to miss out on any
of the the future episodes make sure
that you subscribe
for free it's completely free to listen
to this show
on all of your favorite uh podcast
streaming platforms
and if you have questions topics you'd
love me to cover with future guests
again please send me a message you'll
notice that i'm i'm
actively asking questions from the
audience in the episodes if you want
your questions answered
drop me a message connect with me um and
yeah
so thank you so much for being part of
this journey
i'm i'm really excited to bring you on
the journey as recruitment mentors
um evolves and i hope you
uh continue to get value and enjoy the
the podcast and
i might even see some of you in the
community soon
so thank you again and i'll speak to you